the jurgen experience this i've been
thinking about this a lot lately
and here's an issue um i am
progressive on just about every issue
across the board
gay rights civil rights women's rights
whatever women's right to choose
fill in the blank pro medicaid pro
universal basic income
pro so many things but there's a thing
that happens in
large cities where large cities are
always blue
and i'm trying to figure this out
because like new york so and i used to
think it's always because they're
educated
you know and educated people are more
likely to be compassionate and
compassionate people more likely to be
democrats
but there's a balance that has to be
achieved and
when the [ __ ] hits the fan you need law
and order
and i think that some people who are
democrats who are progressive people
they don't understand that aspect of
human nature or they want to deny that
aspect of human nature like when the
mayor of seattle was dealing with that
whole
six area lockdown little
small little country that they had put
up barriers and [ __ ] and
like literally were had armed guards
there that uh what's it called again
chop chop or chaz right the mayor said
maybe this is our summer of love like no
it's not the summer of love some
people took over other people's
businesses with force
like just because they think the way you
think or they
subscribe to liberal ideas like you like
you're a liberal too
so this is like your gang of thugs that
you have to support when they take over
other people's businesses
no we have to be able to call out
everybody and just because somebody
is on your side you can't let them take
over city blocks and just
institute their own government and then
say it's the summer of love this is
crazy talk
and this is how this is gets get cities
destroyed
and this is what gets the police
defunded and this would what gets
people saying crazy things like we we
need to disband
release everyone from prison and no more
prisons and no more laws and no more
police and like
no the way things go well
is you have to be safe the only way
you're safe is if you have a strong
military
and a strong police force and there's
something about liberals that don't want
to believe that
they see the bad cops they see these
videos
and we all agree we got to get rid of
bad cops they got to reform the police
they have to
but those are not all the cops that's
crazy you just only see the bad no one's
no one's filming excellent interactions
with friendly cops and compliant
uh people that's not what you're filming
not going to get a lot of it's not going
to keep you down
but that's the majority of these
interactions but we have this distorted
perception based on what we're exposed
to
which is viral videos of cops being
[ __ ] because there are cops that are
[ __ ] because there's people that are
[ __ ]
and there's who knows how many [ __ ]
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
cops there are the odds of the not
hundreds and thousands of [ __ ]
is is outrageous well you know what i've
been doing with this whole [ __ ] thing
man
uh because if i get because because you
know me the way my mind goes is not
gonna be like
red state consciousness when it comes to
that [ __ ] because when i saw that
autonomous zone pop up
i'm like let's do it baby spread it out
come on but what did you think would be
good what could good
could have come of that well i mean the
history of america is is
is this in beautiful yet somewhat like
there's a there's a mania a utopian
mania in the heart of i think the
american spirit which is like
americans identify with this it's
you know and george carla did a great
job of desiccating it by saying it's
called the american dream because you
got to be asleep to believe it i love
that joke
but i love the american dream and what's
so beautiful about it
is it's this idea of like i think
together
we can do something new that's going to
be
better than anything that happened
before and from that spirit
you get all great innovation that cuts
goes across
all political ideologies right so to me
you know and they always call it i've
always loved that they call it the
american experiment
[ __ ] love that man because it's an
experiment it's like let's see what we
could do here together and
for an experiment to work we need to be
able to look at what
didn't work in the experiment and
improve upon it now that being said it's
like
for me i've been trying to like pull
myself out
of the even though i identify as a
progressive i'm going to vote democrat
that's just what i'm going to do but
that being said i try to pull myself out
of that
because i don't want to be cubbyholed
man and i have a lot of friends who are
like hardcore conservatives
and i know that there is this idea and i
think a lot of the the idea gets
perpetrated by people
who are into tribalism blue red and so
the the blue people
they propagate uh conceptualization of
the red people
which is kind of what you said well
they're not compassionate yeah
it's like shut the [ __ ] up ridiculous
get the [ __ ] out of here these are some
of the most compassionate people i've
ever met my [ __ ] life
they would die for people episodes of
the joe rogan experience are now
free on spotify that's right they're
free
from september 1st to december 1st
they're going to be available everywhere
but after december 1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love